[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROCHELLE MATTERN:
I'm Roshelle Mattern.
I'm a customer engineer
with the Google Cloud team
and I have the pleasure of
supporting one of our media
and entertainment
customers, Vuclip.
Today with me, I have two
members of the Vuclip team,
Koushik Kulkarni, who's a
technical director at Vuclip,
and Chetan Dixit, who is a
senior director of analytics
and insight at Vuclip.
So today, we're going to be
talking about data warehousing
using a serverless approach
powered by Google Cloud
platform.
So to get us
started, we're going
to start by introducing
some of the challenges
that are commonly associated
with data warehousing
and why that serverless
model came into the picture.
From there, we're
going to move on
to talk about Vuclip's journey
to serverless data warehousing
and talk a little bit about
the technology choices
that they made along the way,
some of the migration process
that they put into place
some of the use cases
that they were able to
implement once they put
the system in place, talk a
little bit about their results
and benefits and
then finally, we're
going to close by doing a
short demo on starting a data
pipeline and moving
into the data warehouse.
So to get us started,
I wanted to introduce
some of the challenges
that are commonly
seen in data warehousing
and why serverless
came into the picture.
So we all hear a lot about
big data lately, right?
And there is a lot
of challenges that
come in to actually
utilizing big data--
you know, integrating the data
together, managing the data,
and then actually
using the data.
And one of the main
components of big data
is a data warehouse.
And traditionally, that
also has its own challenges
associated with it.
So I'm going to start
by introducing three
of the challenges that
are traditionally seen,
and those challenges were
some of the challenges
that Vuclip saw in
their original platform.
So starting with scaling and
performance optimization,
performance can be unpredictable
across various loads.
And that could be due to
limited processing capacity.
Furthermore, as you
need to provision
more and more resources,
the lead time involved
in that can take some time and
lead to delays in the projects
you want to actually
move forward with.
Furthermore, lots of time can
be spent on operational tasks,
and that's not really
where the value add is.
So commonly, you
know, you might have
seen infrastructure
failures and a lot of time
spent on recovery.
And that results in
delays and more effort
spent on operational
tasks, which
is not where the value add is.
Additionally, you have to plan
for licensing and software
upgrades, and that can further
delay your projects, and also
two, take resources from the
things that could be really
adding value to your business.
And then you're having to do
these upgrades, which is not,
you know, the value
add to the business.
And then lastly, data
access retention and tiering
has been a challenge.
So for example, if you need
to provision data access
across the business,
you would have
to provision accounts
across and give passwords
and other such things.
And that can be quite a pain.
So that could lead you
to just not giving access
to people who could be gaining
insights from that data.
And that could lead to limited
ad-hoc querying capabilities
across the business.
And then lastly, data
retention and tiering--
that traditionally has had
to be a manual process,
and that's not an ideal state.
So how do we get
to something that's
more efficient and
easier to manage?
Well, there's four
key components
that need to be put into place,
the first being infrastructure.
You need infrastructure that
is both elastic and reliable,
so that can handle the
scaling needs of your business
and without you having to worry
about the possible downtime
that could lead to those
delays and projects not
being able to be completed.
And then furthermore, you need
data engineering technologies
that can have modern storage
capabilities and also
modern processing tools.
And then also you need
processes in place,
possibly processes that
involves CICD pipelines,
to handle the change
management that you're
going to have to put in
place as you go along.
And then lastly, you need
tools that can actually
integrate with your applications
and business intelligence
tools.
So we need to be able
to consume the data.
So serverless came
into the picture
and addresses some of these
critical components of data
pipelines and data warehousing.
You know, traditionally, there
was a lot of operational tasks
that went into actually
creating a data warehouse.
You know, some of those
were provisioning resources,
handling deployment,
and configuration.
And there was a
small chunk of time
that you actually spent
doing the actual analytics
and getting the insights
that you were looking for.
And then the serverless
model came into the picture,
and that totally
switched the paradigm.
So with serverless,
you are able to spend
a lot more time actually
getting the business value add
and doing the
analytics and getting
the insights that you wanted.
And less time was spent
on the administration.
So with that, I'd like to
introduce Chetan, who's
going to talk to you guys
about some of the technology
decisions that Vuclip
made along their path
and also to talk a little bit
about their migration process.
So Chetan, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
CHETAN DIXIT: Thanks, Rochelle.
And welcome, everyone.
I would like to take
a couple of minutes
to introduce Vuclip, what
we are, and what we do.
So Vu is our premium brand.
We are premium video on
demand streaming company
with a significant presence
in Asian countries,
specifically in Indonesia,
Malaysia, Singapore, Hong Kong.
We do have other products
which are basically B2B,
which we call Vuclip videos.
And there are Vuclip games.
So these are
basically our products
that are offered as VAS
products, Value Added Services,
with different telecoms.
So we have on, on
the Vuclip games,
we have 2000 plus ad-free
games which are developed
by 15 plus developers.
And primarily, we are a
technology driven media
company.
So at the heart of
it is our technology.
So just to give you an idea of
how significantly we are there
on the business, these are
some of the partners whom
with we work across Asia
and Indian subcontinent
and Middle East and Africa
across all of our video games
and Vuclip games.
Now moving onto Vuclip's
journey toward serverless,
so where we were--
so this was our state
of affairs before we
started adopting Google Cloud.
So all of our applications which
were serving our main video
applications are on prem.
Now we had different
applications which were tailor
made for different integrations,
for different telecom partners,
for different telecom
regions, and all that.
So all our data pipelines
were built on prem.
So basically, we hired Kafka
for our data ingestion.
So that was our data
ingestion engine.
And then we used to
have Talend, which
was our premium ETL engine.
And then we had a
bunch of shell scripts
which we used to do
data transformation,
and data was getting loaded
to the GreenPlum, which
was, again, our primary data
warehouse, which was on prem
and then we had a
bunch of Tableau,
servers basically a
couple of Tableau servers,
from where we served
our visualizations.
Whatever pain points were there?
For every new integration
or every new business
that we entered into,
for our insights
to be ahead of that,
what we needed to do
was every time, evaluation
of existing capacity,
how much traffic
this new integration
is going to bring up.
We have to see whether
our Kafka cluster is
going to serve that up.
Then we had to plan for
the manual storage capacity
for our GreenPlum database.
How is our data
going to increase?
So we had to plan
for that as well.
And then at the times, we had to
reshuffle all of the schedules
based on different
geographies because we
have to distribute load
which is whether its
on the GreenPlum for
exhibiting queries
or whether it's Talend for
running different jobs.
So we have to every time
juggle here and there
for our capacity optimization.
So how did we move onto
the Google Cloud Platform.
So basically, the first
approach that we took
was, you know, finding out how
does our data plane look like?
How are the patterns
of ingestion?
So this is where we came up with
our data architecture patterns.
And so basically,
we identified what
are the different components
which are crucial for us
on the Google Cloud.
So if you see the first
three components which
identify the storage,
so different storage,
for different types of
storage, the components
that we identified was
Cloud Storage, BigQuery,
and DataStore.
So these primarily served over
all the persistent storage
requirements.
The next one was Pubsub.
This is, again, storage,
but this served our need
for the transient storage.
So basically we replaced
Kafka with the Pubsub.
Then came the processing.
What are the different
processing things
that we need to use, you know?
That is basically our data
engineering technologies.
So we had Dataflow,
Cloud Functions, and then
App Engine that was identified
as our processing horsepowers.
And then we had Compute Engine.
We used this for orchestration
of all of our pipelines.
So this is how we zeroed
on our components, which
we are going to use for
our different architecture
patterns.
If you look at all of these,
except for Compute Engine,
all are serverless.
So basically, they are
offered as, you know, mainly
as platform as a service.
So you don't have to worry
about the infrastructure aligned
behind it.
Now let me go into the
different architecture patterns
that we have.
So the first is on
the top, we have
our simple, real-time
streaming use case.
So all the data which comes
in from the outside sources
lands on the Pubsub.
Then through Dataflow
streaming pipeline,
it goes to our BigQuery,
which is operational store.
And then the next use
case, which is basically
our low volume and low compute
processing-- so all of our data
this in the batch mode arrives
at the Google Cloud Storage.
For low volume, it gets
processed via the Google Cloud
Functions.
And then data goes again
onto our operational store,
which is BigQuery.
Now for the high volume and
high compute requirements,
data which is landing onto
the Google Cloud Storage
gets processed by the Dataflow,
which is in the batch mode.
That processes data and
goes onto the BigQuery's
operational store.
Now we also have
different indications
which are basically
API-based integration
with internal systems as
well as external systems.
So for this, we use
App Engine, which
is integrated with different
APIs which pull data
from different sources and
then push it onto the BigQuery.
And then last of our case,
which is basically data that we
have-- so data coming
from external sources,
internal systems, and then data
massaging with our own data
and then putting that data
or publishing that data
to the external systems--
so that was, again, a use case.
So on this, we get that data
onto the Google Cloud Storage.
Dataflow amalgamates that
data via out operational data
store and then puts
it onto the Pubsub.
From the Pubsub,
different Cloud functions
get triggered and
sends that data
to their respective
destinations.
So this is our kind
of all of our library
through which we just
keep on extending
and all our use
case gets classified
in all these major buckets.
Now that we had sorted
out our architecture
and how we are
going to attack it,
so basically, that
was our stage of what
we call as proof of technology.
Now the other problem
that we needed
to solve was how do we make
data available to everyone
with access and security?
So data consumption
was our next strategy.
So the way we did
was all our data
was bucketed into two things.
So we had Data Storage project
and Data Access projects.
So the architecture
pattern that we
saw on the operational
Data Store and Data
Warehouse, which was there--
so on the right most.
So those two are the
Data Storage projects.
So only the data gets
ingested over there and access
is not enabled
from these places.
So this is how we
bifurcated that.
Now the way it was managed was
all the data which is there
onto the storage project gets
accessed via the Data Access
project.
The way we do it is we
create different user groups.
So on the different
user groups, they
have different
kinds of privileges.
So all the users who have
access to certain kinds of data,
they will be assigned
to certain groups.
And that is how they will
be able to access that data.
Now the way we created these
BigQuery views was they
are restricted with
timelines and the amount
of columns which are exposed.
For example, the
views would be created
with the restriction of 30
day data, 60 day data, 90 data
data.
For example, the
more raw data it
is, we limit it to
the 30 day, 60 day.
And the more aggregated data
is, we try to make it available
as much as we can.
So what this does
is it enables us
to access, provide access
data securely, to all
of the business users, analysts.
What it also does
is basically, we
can connect all of our
business intelligence tools
to this Data Access project.
So we are never touching
our Data Storage project.
The other thing what it does is
it doesn't duplicate the data.
Our data is still residing
on the Data Storage project
and we still have all the
data available via Data Access
project.
And on top of it,
limiting the amount
of data which is there
onto the Data Access
project, what it does
is it controls the cost
onto the BigQuery.
So the querying
cost gets reduced
because the number
of business users
who are querying that,
they may accidentally
access all the data.
But now you are limiting them.
Now who accesses the
data and what he accesses
and what amount of data
he accesses-- so you
have pretty much control that.
So now that we had sorted
out architecture and data
access, the next thing,
we were onto our journey
towards migration, the
actual project, the migrating
from in-house on prem
to the Google Cloud.
The first set like I talked
was the proof of technology
and then actual development.
In this, we got our
data and then, you know,
started developing the pieces
that we explained earlier.
In the first phase, our systems
were live on prem as is,
and we started our
development and testing,
and we tested with
all the use cases.
And then next important
step in the migration
was the data migration.
Whatever the historical
data we had--
so that was our longest
portion which took time.
So we moved all of our
historical data onto the GCP
as well as our
reporting system still
was live with our
old on-prem systems.
In the next phase, we
did the parallel run.
So basically, streaming data
was going onto both the systems.
So we had historical
data, and streaming data
was now going to both the
systems on prem as well as GCP.
Now once the data was
going on to the GCP,
we enabled reporting for a
few pilot things from the GCP.
So all of our reporting
for the business
was now for the pilot projects.
We expose them through the GCP.
Once we started out
issues with the pilots
and we were good to go, then
we actually moved onto--
all of the products
onto the GCP.
There, we disconnected reporting
from the on prem system.
We had streaming
data which was still
going to the on prem that
was just as a backup,
still going to the on prem.
And then our streaming data
was going onto the GCP.
All of our reporting
was done from the GCP.
And then in the final stage,
we cut off our on-prem systems.
And as this moment,
we have everything
running onto the GCP.
OK, so we have made our journey
reaching till, you know, GCP.
Everything is there.
But it is not stagnant.
Every day, there will be changes
which will keep on coming in.
You have to change
your pipelines.
You have to change your
logics and all that.
So what is the most
important thing, then?
So you need to have continuous
deployment processes and test
processes which will
take care of things
like compute creation,
packages, create installations,
whether its an SDK upgrade or
some library in Java, Python.
You need to take care of
storage creations, the buckets,
folders, the management of that.
The BigQuery tables, view
creation, their [INAUDIBLE],,
anything--
Pubsub and Dataflow pipelines.
So all of these things you
need to take care of in order
to be able to run your
systems into the GCP.
Once you migrated, that is
not the end of the journey,
actually.
Your journey begins from there.
Now having said
that, let's actually
go into a few of our
use cases in detail
to get the gist
of it-- you know,
what are the complex
things we are solving.
To go into these
use cases, I would
like to call upon Koushik.
[APPLAUSE]
KOUSHIK KULKARNI:
Thank you, Chetan,
and thank you Google
Next Team and Rochelle
for allowing us to present what
we have done so far on GCP.
So what is available,
you have already
seen that what is available.
Now what we can do with all of
these tools and technologies
that we have--
the first use case came
right from our migration from
the in-house system
to Google Cloud--
data marts and dashboards.
Everyone has those.
We also had some.
We had to keep them running
when we migrated the data.
So initially, we started working
with the application logs,
plain application logs.
The streaming logs were
ingested through Pubsub
by the streaming
Dataflow pipelines
that you see over there.
And then the batch data was
first extracted onto GCS
and then loaded onto BigQuery.
One of the fantastic
features that we used,
that was flexible schemas.
So that basically
allowed us to adapt
to the upstream logs event model
changes in almost real time.
And then we used the
aggregate data marts
to create-- basically, we
use the SQL, BigQuery SQL,
to create the
aggregated data marts.
These were then used by the
dashboards and visualizations.
Initially, we started
with Tableau on prem
because we were not sure of the
[INAUDIBLE] platform stability.
Once it got stabilized, we
migrated Tableau to online.
Then we had some partner reports
and third party data extracts
which actually were enabled
by the aggregate data
marts themselves.
Then along the line came
YouTube data requirements.
So we are a media company
as you all know now.
So we have our YouTube channels.
From there, we wanted to
get our engagement data.
So the BigQuery transfer
services fitted right in.
I mean, with a few
clicks, we were
able to enable the
Dataflows and start
measuring the user engagements.
Cost-- cost is definitely
an important factor
that you should not ignore.
So all our GCP billing
data, that is the--
which all jobs are getting
triggered, which all users are
using these services, what
are the number of bytes
they are processing, what
is the chargeable cost--
everything is exported now
to the BigQuery itself.
So you can create dashboards
and alerts based on that.
The next use case is around
user journey management.
Now this actually originated
from the need of our product
team to tweak the application
experience for each user.
So this earlier-- we had
some of the ideas that
were identified that
we should probably
offer these kind of offers
to a certain region.
Or we should change the way,
you know, the sign up flow
works in certain regions.
But then for each
of those changes,
we needed longer
application chain cycles.
To tackle that, we created this
kind of user journey management
system.
The first one in the system
is basically the user data--
user master data.
So all of that obligations
actually generate logs.
We ingest those.
We create the central
user view using Dataflow.
And we push those user
changes onto Pubsub.
To create the
segments themselves,
like user segmentation
and then attaching
certain policies which are how
the application should behave
at a certain given
customization point,
we created a user interface.
That was hosted on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
The backend APIs for that were
provided by Cloud Functions.
The backend data store was
chosen to be DataStore.
Once the configuration is
done from this particular UI,
the messages flow through
Pubsub to Dataflow
again where, in a
distributed manner,
it decouples or it
basically resolves
the segment and their
priorities for each user
and creates user
level configuration.
And that then is
pushed again to Pubsub.
From there, it is
available to any consumer.
So we have various kinds of
applications that we run.
We have mobile browser.
We have application Android IOS
and whatnot and also backend.
Some of the functionality is
governed by the backend itself.
So all of that can then
subscribe to the cross cloud
configurable system.
And what worked here really
well for us is the Dataflow
windowing basically--
so I think we have seen some of
the windowing in other sessions
also.
The session level windows,
late arrival of data,
custom triggering based
on certain panes, that
really worked well
for us in this case.
The Pubsub subscriptions,
we created basically a push
subscription to AWS systems
also from where it is
served to the AWS applications.
And Pubsub handles those push
subscriptions with retries
with exponential backups also.
So a lot of boilerplate code has
really been eliminated for us.
The next use case was around
event-based optimizations.
So as you see, there are some
attribution related events
that we are ingesting
using App Engine.
That is actually being fed to
the reference data preparation
which is handled in Dataflow.
The persistent data, the
reference data for each user
is hosted in DataStore.
And then that is actually used
by another Dataflow process
which handles batch and
stream events to prepare
or enrich those events.
And again, they are queued
for dispatch in Pubsub.
From there, the Cloud Functions
have custom event preparation
and dispatch, which is then sent
to AppsFlyer and MoreEngage.
So we are basically trying to
reward the ad networks which
are providing high quality
users as well as we are trying
to engage more with
the users if they are
showing some kind of behavior.
So all of that was
actually enabled
by this particular application.
And advanced analytics--
who can forget that?
So this is one of
the simple use cases
that we did where we wanted it
to understand how our customer
or what actually they
are talking about us
across various countries.
So we have presence
across a lot of countries,
and that basically comes
with the understanding
that there are various
languages that are
being used in these countries.
So we started-- how
we went about this?
We started with taking the
customer data loading into GCS.
We used [INAUDIBLE]
Cloud Functions
to load this data into
BigQuery whenever that came in.
And from there, we
used translation API
to translate all of those
various different languages,
feedback in different
languages, into English.
From there, we use
[INAUDIBLE] based
classification and
natural language
API for sentiment analysis.
And we basically created
some sort of NPS,
if you will, and
again visualized it
in dashboard in Tableau online.
So the use case
actually highlights
usage of ML algorithms
that are out of the box,
and they actually come with
a very good architecture
that you can use without
doing a lot of coding.
They are very well-tested,
so you don't really
have to worry about the
retraining and everything.
And you can prototype
quickly, right?
So you can deliver
the business use case
while it is still relevant.
So in general,
what we understand
from all of these use cases
is that we can focus--
using all of these
cloud components,
we can focus on our
architecture and focus
on our business use case
rather than the boilerplate.
We do have to plan for capacity.
We do have to watch for
cost, even those are actually
provided by the Cloud platform.
And of course get help.
And you know, on the support
as well as on Stackdriver
and everywhere, we are talking
about how these components
and utilities are changing
so that we can keep updated
with the latest features.
So what are the results and
benefits from all of this?
So this is now the
latest footprint
that we have in Google Cloud.
There are around 40 plus
streaming pipelines, 50
plus BigQuery data sets,
as many GCS buckets,
talking about 75 plus
terabytes of data.
There are 100 billion
rows of data in all.
And we're talking about 300 to
400 million events every day.
And there are 1,000
plus pipelines
that are getting
spawned and destroyed
after the work is done.
So we don't really have
to worry about any kind
of infrastructure management.
The benefits are,
first of all, reduced
redundant infrastructure.
We always see that.
Earlier, we had
in-house data platform.
Now, you know, we don't really
have to manage anything.
And once the use case is served,
it just tears down itself.
High availability-- so earlier,
if certain traffic increased,
then we would
basically see failures
in some of the components
which would actually cause,
you know, availability
to be hampered.
But now that doesn't
happen anymore.
Faster implementations--
earlier,
our implementation time used
to span around three days.
Now it has been
reduced to 30 minutes.
Infrastructure management
overhead-- around two people
use to actually
continuously do something
to keep the in-house
infrastructure up.
Now they are freed and they
can do something better.
On-demand scale up
and scale down--
so around 35
transactions per second
to 500 transactions
per second is just
supported without any change.
The App Engine and
Dataflow instances
just scale up by themselves
and then again scale down.
On the ML and advanced
analytics front,
ready-made and
battle-tested algorithms--
as I said, we just need
a very little amount
of coding to start them using.
And faster value realization--
I mean, this is one of the areas
that I really love about it.
So we wanted to make changes.
We want to respond to
business quickly rather than
getting involved in the same
kind of boilerplate code.
So all of the Google
Cloud Platform
has really taken that pain
out of the development cycle
and we now can focus solely
on the delivery itself.
So with that, we'll quickly see
a demo of one of the use cases
that we have implemented.
For that, I'll call upon
Chetan and I'll start my prayer
to the demo gods.
[APPLAUSE]
CHETAN DIXIT: Thanks, Koushik.
So so far, we have been
talking so much, right?
My fingers crossed for
the demo, but let's see.
So what we're going to do
is we are going to give you
a glimpse of what can be done.
Can you flip back
to the presentation?
OK.
So just to give
you an idea of what
we are going to demo-- so
we're going to give you
a glimpse of how easy it is to
start an end-to-end pipeline
with all components
and [INAUDIBLE] all
your data ready to ingest
into your BigQuery.
So we'll pull the
cord from repository.
We'll create you BigQuery
datasets and tables.
We'll create storage buckets
and asset folders inside that.
We'll create Pubsub
topics and subscriptions.
Then we'll launch a
streaming Dataflow pipeline.
And we'll also schedule
a batch pipeline which
we will invoke
manually, and then we'll
see the aggregated results.
Can we go back to the demo?
OK.
So here's exactly what I
just showed you on the slide.
Before we go there, let's
quickly do a quick check.
So we don't have anything here.
There are no datasets, tables.
There are no topics
and subscriptions here.
There are no pipelines
running so far.
Let's go here.
Let's quickly check.
And there are no scheduled
jobs here as well.
Now I've kicked off the
pipeline to deploy everything.
So first, it will get the
code from the big bucket.
Then it will create BigQuery
tables, Pubsub topics
and subscriptions, and
storage buckets and folders.
Meanwhile, let's quickly
check [INAUDIBLE] the time.
We have our dataset created.
We have one table
created as well.
But you see here it's only a
table which is a static schema
table which is created.
And there's no data in it.
Let's go here.
OK, we have got
the topic created
with the name Next 2018 demo.
And we have a subscription
associated with it.
OK, let's go to here.
So it is still
launching the pipeline.
It has created storage.
Let's quickly go to storage.
So pipeline is also launched.
We see here it's running.
Now it's putting a
scheduled job over there.
It has all finished.
Now let's do one thing.
There's no point if we can't
put the data over there.
So right now, we don't
see any other table.
It's just the summary
table which is there.
So now I'll try to put
some data over here.
Now we are receiving data.
Now the thing to look at it is
now it's not tied to a schema.
It will create the tables
according to whatever data
I'm putting under it.
Still not yet?
This is the pipeline.
It is running in.
It is yet to get the data.
See, this was--
table wasn't there.
So this table got
created depending
on the payload which
was there that I
was publishing under the topic.
Let's do a preview of this.
So this table has
steaming buffer.
Let me just query it.
That is the data which is
getting streamed just now.
Now we'll go back here.
There's a scheduled job here.
So there was no
data here in this.
So now we have
completed end to end.
The data is getting
pumped in in real time,
and we have just
ran a job which just
summarizes data on this one.
So this is just public data
set which is NYC taxi trip
data available in the BigQuery.
It's the same day that
we took, and we just
completed a simple
pipeline, which takes data
onto the Pubsub, streams
it, process it, stores
onto the BigQuery,
and then summarizes,
and it's ready for
consumption here.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we go back to
the presentation?
OK, so we have seen the demo.
What next?
So with serverless,
pay as you go.
Build fast with cutting edge
tools from Google Cloud,
on demand scale up to scale out.
Yes, definitely experience
serverless with GCP.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]